-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here with
Congresswoman Ocasio-Cortez.
So I feel like for two years
we talked about
who's going to win the House.
And then for weeks we covered
who's going to be the Speaker.
And then since Kevin McCarthy
got the gavel, I -- nothing.
I feel like we
barely hear anything.
For someone
who's up close to it,
what do you feel the GOP
is trying to do with this power?
-Yeah, well, first of all,
you're absolutely right.
I believe this is the least
productive first three months
under almost any Speaker
potentially in the history
of the United States,
if not in modern
political history.
And I think it's because,
you know,
they talked a lot
about winning,
but they didn't really plan
for what they wanted to do.
So they're kind of
sitting around
and they're looking
at state legislatures
and they're like,
"Maybe we can ban books."
And we say, "No,
you should not do that."
And I think
they're, you know --
I'm so grateful that we have
a Democratic Senate
and that folks turned out
and elected so many incredible
members of the Senate
to be a kind
of a stop on that.
But I just think
they don't really know.
And I also think Kevin McCarthy
promised so many people
so many different things
that he cannot possibly govern
with all these pre-commitments
that he's made.
-A way to, I guess,
seem like you're doing something
while also not governing
is to complain about wokeism
and how it affects
everything from bank
collapses to the way
our military is being run.
Is that -- Are you in actual
meetings and committee hearings
where that is the sort of
topic du jour?
-Oh, yeah.
House Republicans held an
entire -- an entire hearing
on "wokeism"
in the federal government
and federal employment policies.
And so I'm looking at it.
I'm like, "What is so woke
that has them so outraged?"
And I look through this list
and I'm like,
oh, paying members
of the Forest Service
more than a Walmart greeter,
using remote work
for people with disabilities
and people who live
in rural areas,
you know, healthcare,
and like --
it's just a catch-all term
that they use for anything
that they don't like.
-And I guess
one of the problems
is when they actually get to
legislating on things like that,
even their constituents
wouldn't want to lose things
like healthcare,
especially when
they realize wokeism
has nothing to do with it.
-Yeah, I think
that's why they have to
call it wokeism
because if they actually told
their constituents,
"Hey, we don't want the Forest
Service folks to get paid well,"
people would be like,
"Why do you want to do that?"
And so I think they have to
brand it as all this stuff.
And I mean,
they'll say it often.
I was on the floor of a debate
around some of their work
in trying to ban books and they
call it "parental rights"
but they try to package this
and use misdirection
to say "we want parents
to be more involved
and have more of a say
in their school."
Well, if you want that,
maybe let's create a society
where parents aren't working
two jobs
so that they can be
more involved
with their kids in school.
[ Applause ]
Instead of trying
to tell people
that trans kids should not have
a safe place to get an education
or tell their parents
what to do.
I mean, it's, you know,
I think it speaks to the fact
that despite no matter
what happens with Donald Trump,
Trumpism is still alive.
And we've seen it recently.
There was just a vote
in the Tennessee
state legislature to expel
three Democratic representatives
in their legislature
because they had the audacity
to stand up and protest
for gun-safety legislation
because the state of Tennessee
was not acting enough.
And so instead
of having vigorous debate,
the folks who accuse people
of silencing
are the ones who are silencing
and expelling.
The folks who are accusing
people of intimidation,
like Marjorie
Taylor Greene today.
You know, we have --
New York City Public Advocate
Jumaane Williams is blowing
a whistle while she was talking.
I mean, we all have our First
Amendment right, right?
She goes around
calling this intimidation.
And it's so often
this politics of projection
in order to get you
to become defensive
about what this person --
defensive towards yourself
about what the other person
is actually doing,
and we just need to move
out of that space
because I think
what most people just want
is for us to actually
accomplish something
as a government
that helps working people.
-You have also,
or I should say
the GOP has also promised
to get to the bottom
of the Biden crime family
and their term, not mine.
-Yeah.
-It does not seem
as though, you know, again,
as you said, three months,
no breaking news.
-Yeah. I mean, I think --
they've tried, you know.
They had that big
Twitter, Hunter Biden hearing
and they're like,
"We got him."
And then the thing
about hearings is that
they're not Republican
press conferences.
You have 50 Democrats that are
also or however many Democrats
in the committee
that are also seated on that.
And they can real-time
fact-check you,
unlike Fox News,
as a "safe space" for them.
You know, you can get
fact-checked in real time.
You will be debated
in real time.
And they have operated
in this insular environment
that affirms them,
no matter how true or false,
anything they say
is that now
that they're actually
in a House majority
and they have to
actually call hearings
and they actually
have to legislate
and they actually have
to be called on things
when they're not true,
they're like, "Wait, this
doesn't feel like
Tucker Carlson to me."
[ Laughter ]
It's like, no, baby, this is the
U.S. House of Representatives.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-There you go.
Well, if there's any lesson
they take away from that,
I hope that's it.
Hey, what a pleasure
to have you back here.
It's always -- to have
a New Yorker here, especially
one -- the beautiful --
from the beautiful LaGuardia.
I mean, the most beautiful
airport in the whole world.
-Look at the fountain
when you go.
-Look at the fountain.
-Book your next flight.
-It's gorgeous.
-It's worth flying from Europe
just to land at JFK, drive
to LaGuardia.
Look at it. Drive back to JFK,
go back to Europe.
-What I will say, though,
is Moynihan Train Hall --
Let's put another one
for public transit over there.
The new train hall, Amtrak.
I love it too.
-The Moynihan Train Hall is
great.
This is very exciting.
You know, things have
really turned around
since you got here.
You guys, give it up for
Congresswoman Alexandria
Ocasio-Cortez.
-We'll be right back
with more "Late Night."